Ich glaube, das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Test ah wait a minute das hat irgendwie ich laber die ganze zeit schon mit euch mann
das hat irgendwas umgestellt wieder ganz bescheuert wartet mal sound options recording man kann
auch sagen die folgt die weiß set default habe ich doch warum warum ging das jetzt schon
wieder nett muss man nicht verstehen oder naja gut so da kann ich das jetzt ganz ja noch
mal erzählen weil irgendwie hatte keiner mitgekriegt was ich erzählt habe weil das
mikrofon kaputt war ich weiß ich bin außerplanmäßig da heute aber ich gehe
heute erst nachmittags wandern und nicht vormittags weil ich hatte vorstellungsgespräch
heute heute vormittag und ich habe jetzt zeit ich habe ordentlich was gefuttert eine runde
p-profett gemacht da habe ich mir gedacht wir können jetzt einfach ein bisschen weiter basteln
an diesem amazon mqtt ding so dass es sich gescheit bedienen lässt nicht so eklig wie
dieses amazon beispiel und ich habe jetzt einfach mal so zwei zweieinhalb stunden zeit und da dachte
ich mir so besser als sinnlos vorm rechner setzen wir einfach stream an aber ich warte
jetzt erst mal bis twitch das richtig mitgekriegt hat dass der stream on ist ich meine so viele
leute werden um montags um 12 uhr 30 jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht da sein aber mehr
als fünf sollten es wahrscheinlich sein mein melden mehr als fünf sollten schon sein normalerweise
sind so 250 bis 350 schwankt immer aber fünf ist vielleicht auch für montag vorstellungsgespräch
als senior devops engineer senior development was ja senior devops engineer so die exakten
wortlaut weiß ich aus dem kopf gerade gar nicht ach ja jetzt jetzt hat twitch gecheckt
dass der stream on ist kann ich ja kann ich ja gleich alles noch mal erzählen weil es
eh keiner mitgekriegt hat deswegen macht man normalerweise so ein bisschen vier fünf minuten
vor den streamern zumindest alle großen hrq streamer machen das aber ich bin ja kein
großer hrq streamer also hrq ähnlich und groß auch nicht also beides zusammen vielleicht
gibt es auch wieder plus ne ne ne das ist auch gar nicht gesagt mit manchen antworten hatte
ich den eindruck waren sie nicht so ganz glücklich aber gut kann ich nichts machen weil letztendlich
müssen ja beide seiten damit damit zufrieden sein ja also beide seiten müssen irgendwie
damit leben können ein großer hrq würde das anime aiya girl zweimal abspielen ist das
so und was ist wenn man das was ist wenn man das sogar dreimal abspielt steinadler fünf
dankeschön für den sub
zählt das als fortbildung wenn ich ja wenn du was machst wenn du wenn du entwickler bist
und irgendwas mit aws zu tun hast denke ich schon so jetzt sind wir irgendwo stehen geblieben
muss ich gleich mal gucken mal gucken also so um 15 uhr oder in dem dreh muss ich wahrscheinlich
auch wieder weg mal gucken wie gesagt ich muss noch eine wandertour absolvieren heute
habe ich euch ja im letzten video erzählt dass ich das jeden tag mache aber heute vormittag
wie gesagt vorstellungsgespräch gehabt da hatte ich keine zeit wandern zu gehen und
jetzt ist so genau über den mittag und ich habe gerade gefuttert da kann ich jetzt auch
nicht wandern gehen deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach zweieinhalb stunden mittags mittags
stream ja für alle die fragen wollen wie ist das vorstellungsgespräch gelaufen an
sich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht also an sich würde ich sagen relativ gut auch wenn
ich überhaupt keine übung habe wirklich was vorstellungsgespräche angeht ich glaube nur
dass so die ein und andere antwort nicht so gut angekommen ist zum beispiel dass ich so
sehr auf 100 prozent homeoffice gepocht habe beziehungsweise auf 99 prozent homeoffice
und vier tage woche hat sie auch ziemlich überrascht sich gesagt habe ja ich will aber
nur vier tage die woche aber gut ich meine letztendlich dazu sind vorstellungsgespräche
da ja dass die was mitkriegen dass ich was mitkriege und am endeffekt wenn man halt sagt
hey passt beiden seiten dann ist gut wenn man sagt hier passt irgendwie in einer seite
nicht dann halt nicht dafür ist es ja letztendlich da aber ja keinen sinn da irgendwelche zusagen
zu machen egal von einer in die andere richtung die dann im endeffekt nicht gehalten werden
kann hatte keinen sinn und ich habe auch gesagt also meiner erfahrung nach schafft man schaffe
ich mit oder schafft man mit vier tagen auch nicht so viel weniger als mit fünf aber gut
schauen wir mal mal gucken was rauskommt also ich finde die motivation in gewisser weise
ist schon übergesprungen die die leute dort ausstrahlen aber ich weiß nicht ob sie damit
mein vier tage woche mit meiner vier tage woche und meine homeoffice geschichte so glücklich
sind aber gut man letztendlich muss man sich einig werden und dann passt es oder halt nicht
ansonsten würde ich halt abhaken habe ich auch mal wieder vorstellungsgespräch geübt
mal gucken ich bin gespannt was kommt gucken wir uns zweite bewerbungsrunde gibt ob es
die überhaupt gibt müssen wir gucken das war das erste mal dass ich tatsächlich in
einem lebenslauf web video produzent drin stehen hatte stell euch das mal vor sowas
sind wir schon ich habe aber technik glaube ich da vorgeschrieben selbstständig nebenberuflich
web die technik web video produzent irgendwie sowas habe ich geschrieben kann ich eben machen
weil ich habe mein guitar profil verlinkt ja und von meinem guitar profil kommt zu super
easy auf mein youtube channel beziehungsweise auf erstmal auf mein twitch channel dann auf
mein youtube channel hast du eine empfehlung wollte eine steckdose wo ich mit einer api
drauf zugreifen kann um zum beispiel verbrauch auszulesen ja und nee ich weiß nicht ob es
also die letzte steckdose die mir bekannt ist die sich noch flaschen ließ die da das
war die letzte steckdosen leiste die mir bekannt ist die sich noch flaschen ließ das ist nicht
wirklich von hammer das ist ein herrscht das ist in china chinesen hersteller da habe
ich ganz viele von ja von unterschiedlichen brands quasi immer die gleiche also das ist
die letzte steckdosen leiste die ich gefunden habe die sich noch flaschen lässt ist aber
auch schon wieder ein halbes jahr wo ich die geflascht habe das heißt da musste gucken
ob die sich noch flaschen lässt wie ist die bestellnummer bei amazon kommst du da jetzt
drauf hier unten hier arsene brauchst du gär hier da guck ich kann dir aber einfach
einen link in den chat posten wenn du willst aber wie gesagt du musst das ausprobieren
hier du musst das ausprobieren ob das noch geht ich kann dir das nicht sagen also viele
leute sagen anscheinend es geht noch mit tas motor wenn ich das wenn ich das richtig sehe
nicht englisch tas motor ja also januar ging es anscheinend noch tas motor flaschen möglich
juni september ne juni noch möglich musst du gucken ob es geht dann ist es optimal da
musst du nicht aufmachen sondern kanns ota flaschen das ganze nein brauchst du nicht
du flascht das damit du brauchst den raspberry pi du flascht das guck im streamer schief
wir haben das schon hier on stream paar mal gemacht exakt diese gleichen steckdosen leiste
brauchst du den raspberry pi mit dieser geschichte drauf dann kannst du die flaschen mit tas
motor und das motor hast du ein web interface hast du http arpi mqtt arpi home assistant
integration guck dir guck dir einfach den stream an dazu nee hab ich nicht hab ich nicht
ich hab zwar ein beausrufe zeichen hetze aber der geht aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht
was auch immer war war es nett jetzt läuft mir die nass top fang an zu stream nass läuft
super so muss es sein max ich hoffe du bist frisch so was von frisch so wo sind wir stehengeblieben
das ist das letzte mal also internet of things ist iot ja ja korrekt beste das klo beste
klo neuer job nicht so hä wie kommst du da drauf ich hab da noch gar keinen neuen job
ich hatte vorhin vorstellungsgespräch und ich glaube mit ein zwei antworten waren sie
nicht so ganz glücklich aber gut unterm strich müssen beide seiten mit happy sein ansonsten
ist besser man merkt das früher als später ich habe halt ich habe halt auf 99 prozent
home office bestanden ich gesagt habe hier also ist mir der wichtigste wichtigste faktor
zumal das auch eine ganze weg von mir stück von mir weg ist und dass ich halt nur vier
tage woche arbeite ich dachte eigentlich das wissen die schon aber das wussten die gar
nicht deswegen musste ich halt noch mal erzählen obwohl ich es an sich echt gut fand die haben
gewisse motivation versprüht die leute dort das kenne ich so von meinem aktuellen job gar
nicht und das ist schon ein bisschen übergesprungen ja fand ich wirklich der pure anblick motivierter
leute motivierend warum 99 prozent weil ich keine schmerzen mit habe zu speziellen
events doch mal hinzufahren also sei es jetzt irgendwie irgendwelche kickoff events oder
so ja wenn das mal so eine handvoll im jahr ist meinetwegen soll mir recht sein aber ich
will halt nicht dass man sagt hey ein tag die woche weil dann bringt mir das nix dann
fahre ich zwei stunden in zwei stunden zurück einmal die woche das ja schlechter als bei
meinem aktuellen job weiß schon was bei dir geklappt hat gibt ja IT technisch gibt es
ja wirklich aktuell total viel zeug so wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben fiat zeug also
ich erzähle euch mal kurz was wir das letzte mal gemacht haben nur für den fall der fälle
dass ihr nicht dabei gewesen seid aber mal gucken ob ich mich noch connecten kann mit
den alten credentials kackel ne geht nicht ok also folgendermaßen einmal die woche zum
office wandern ja zwei stunden nicht zu fuß zwei stunden mit dem zug und das halt auch
nur wenn es gut funktioniert also wenn die bahn damit macht das ist halt so eines meiner
kürzten probleme das ist ja auch das was mich am homeoffice am an diesem anwesenheit anwesend
sein da am meisten nervt bei meinem aktuellen job dass die bahn da eben nicht mitspielt
zwei stunden mit dem zug ja zwei stunden in zwei stunden zurück deswegen deswegen ist
wir halt 99 prozent homeoffice auch so wichtig sonst kann ich den job nicht machen das funktioniert
und ich glaube gehalstechnisch haben sie auch geschluckt aber was soll ich sagen ein bisschen
verbessern muss man sich und weniger verdienen als vorher will ich auch nicht ja jetzt wohl
zwei stunden ist zu viel ja eine stunde und wenn es dann halt auch nicht auf die bahn
angewiesen ist dann kann man es ja machen aber ansonsten also ich fahre von hanau aus
ungefähr eineinhalb stunden regulär mit dem zug und dann müsste ich da halt noch eine
halbe stunde laufen oder irgendwie anders weit ich dann dahin fahren das ist schlicht
und ergreifend zu lang wieviel hast du während der ausbildungszeit verdient ich habe absolut
keine ahnung mehr das war 2007 ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung weiß ich wirklich nicht
mehr ich ich würde ich würde es dir sagen wenn ich es wüsste ich weiß es nicht mehr
auf erst fünf minuten mit dem auto ja das natürlich dann auch gut ja da hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen weniger schmerzen mit ja müsste ich nur fünf minuten 15 minuten
um die ecke fahren dann hätte ich damit zwei tagen oder so anwesenheit im büro oder 50
prozent anwesenheit im büro vielleicht auch kein problem aber ich will halt nicht mich
quasi fast schon am anderen ende der welt bewerben um es übertrieben zu sagen und dann
dahin fallen muss es muss home office sein es geht nicht an ich kann den job sonst nicht
sonst sonst nicht machen die neue job bezeichnung ich habe die stellenanzeige jetzt gerade nicht
hier ist irgendwas es ist entweder senior devops engineer oder es ist senior linux engineer
oder es ist oder es ist senior development things engine irgendwie was ich weiß es gar
nicht genau ich glaube ich glaube senior devops engineer war es ich kann es dir wirklich nicht
hundertprozentig sagen aus dem kopf wie es genau lautete aber deine strecke dürfte die
schlechteste sein hier meine strecke also hanau frankfurt beziehungsweise dann hanau
ja noch andere richtung ist halt mist du bist auf der suche nach c sharp entwickler da bist
du nicht nach mir auf der suche auf jeden fall ich meine ich kann zwar c sharp und ich kann
das gar nicht schlecht aber ich glaube ich will nicht als hauptberuflicher entwickler
arbeiten also jetzt mal zu der geschichte wo ich ein bisschen weiter basteln will wo
wir in einem beletzten stream schon angefangen haben ach du suchst du suchst zur stelle als
dort entwickler also verstehe verstehe also folgendermaßen ich jetzt ich erkläre euch
das mal kurz ein neues nee kein neues issue alt altes issue habe ich vorhin schon drauf
geantwortet also folgendermaßen ich habe hier so einen plugin programmiert für home assistant
wo man von seinem fiat daten abziehen kann so und der fiat der verschickt über amazon
über den amazon mqtt service verschickt er ab und zu noch weitere infos nämlich zum
beispiel ob der ladevorgang fertig ist oder ob er in spezielles gebiet fährt oder nicht
da kann man zum beispiel dann mitbekommen ob das auto direkt vor der haustür steht und
wenn das auto vor der haustür steht das ist für elektroautos das geht aber auch für
andere wichtig ist also wenn du es ausprobieren willst wichtig ist nicht dass du ein elektroauto
hast wenn du elektroauto hast ist die chance höher dass es funktioniert aber alle anderen
gehen auch du musst gucken ob es ob dein auto mit diesen seiten funktioniert also wenn
du ein fiat hast muss es mit dem funktionieren und so weiter du musst gucken du musst gucken
ob es damit funktioniert wenn es damit funktioniert ist die chance relativ hoch dass das plugin
funktioniert und wenn es plugin nicht funktioniert aber es mit einem dieser seiten funktioniert
dann ist die chance auch sehr hoch dass man es einbauen kann sollte es nicht funktionieren
ja also jeep jeep geht angeblich er sagt jetzt zum beispiel jeep geht doch nicht zumindest
das auto kommuniziert über amazon mqtt da kann man dann zum beispiel auslesen wie gesagt
ladevorgang und was halt richtig cool ist das auto kann nachrichten schicken über amazon
mqtt zum beispiel wenn es ein spezielles gebiet betrifft betritt oder da kann ich gleich
was zu sagen wenn es ein bestimmtes bestimmtes gebiet in ein bestimmtes gebiet reinfährt
oder rausfährt also zum beispiel könntest du dann deine einfahrt markieren auf einer
karte und wenn das auto halt in die einfahrt reinfährt oder rausfährt dann bekommst du
das mit und kannst dann zum beispiel das hof drauf machen oder so oder solche geschichten
das ding ist halt das geht über amazon beziehungsweise mit dem mqtt broker von von amazon den amazon
also den aws iot core services das ist ein bisschen kompliziert zu benutzen aber es
ist eine coole funktion gerade wenn man damit das hof dort zum beispiel auf und zu machen
kann wir haben es letztens im stream ausprobiert das ganze programmiertechnisch anzusprechen
das blöde war bloß dass das extrem ekliger source code ist hier guckt euch das mal an
was die was die jungs da von amazon fabriziert haben das will ich ein bisschen aufräumen
dass das normal nach normalem dotnet aussieht und vielleicht mache ich das ganze auch als
extra extra package dann auf github falls andere das problem haben aber es ist eklig
zu benutzen also so will ich will das nicht so eins zu eins bei mir hier reinkopieren
also das ist abartig ich meine das ist zumindest schön kommentiert man kann es irgendwo auch
lesen aber das geht auf jeden fall besser man darf das ist ja aber weitem auch nicht
alles die waren zum beispiel so frei bei amazon und haben eine eigene url encode methode programmiert
wobei jedes dotnet framework der letzten jahre nur encode dabei hat das ist nicht schön
das versuchen wir mal ein bisschen ordentlicher zu machen jetzt ja und auf die frage warum
es für keine deutschen marken geht ist ganz einfach weil die kanu connect verwenden sondern
irgendwas eigenes das hier ist alles fiat was heißt das fiat chrysler was steht denn
das a fiat chrysler automobiles ok und das das ist das geht nur für alle fiat chrysler
dinger die connect verwenden dankreich reno die verwenden auch kein uconnect die haben
auch was eigenes wie gesagt mir ist aktuell nur von diesen fünf herstellern bekannt dass
sie einen uconnect service anbieten der mit dem addon funktioniert fiat jeep ram trucks
das ist so da stehen die amis drauf freedom car dodge ist auch so ein ami ding und alfa
romeo ist weiß nicht irgendwas italienisches auch glaubt ja und halt auch es gehen halt
auch nur die neuesten die die die neuen uconnect services verwenden die die alten hier die
mopar.com und sowas verwenden die gehen gar nicht kann ich auch nichts machen ist sowies
es die ap ist halt nur so da aber ganz ehrlich wenn ihr ein anderes auto habt und das beispielsweise
in eure smart home geschichte einbinden wollt da gibt es höchstwahrscheinlich auch was
für die meisten deutschen integration also bmw guckt mal home assistant integrations
ich glaube bmw gibt es von haus aus schon bmw gibt es von haus aus und ich glaube mercedes
gibt es auch ok aber bmw gibt es auf jeden fall welche welche plattform ist das muss
man dann vielleicht mal nach nach auto oder so oder k nach k gucken wir mal also standardmäßig
kann home assistant kann schon bmw dacia ist das china chinesen zeug oder ist das japanisches
zeug was ist das ach nee französisches zeug ist das echt das ist das echt was französisches
an die rumänien ich dachte dass es irgendwas china chinesen mäßiges wusste ich gar nicht
gut ich habe von autos auch keine ahnung ja weiß ich nicht was es ist weiß ich auch nicht
was es ist missa kann anscheinend auch standardmäßig reno kann home assistant auch schon sebarro
kanns auch matz da ja und das ist eben der android app also das sind die standardmäßig
in home assistant integrierten module es gibt aber auch noch jede menge andere plugins und
addons für home assistant für andere autos unter anderem mines eben für fiat aber hiermit
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich am glücklichsten weil es offizielle integrations sind das wusste
ich gerne dass das zusammen aber wie gesagt ich habe von autos eh keine ahnung keinen
plan okay wo sind wir stehen geblieben
wo sind wir stehen geblieben ja ich will das ganze mal hier ein bisschen ordentlich machen
access key secret key token müssen wir uns gleich noch mal einen fake account bei fiat
generieren um das auszuprobieren dass das funktioniert ich muss mal kurz meine einrückung
wieder ordentlich machen ich hab die eigentlich auf zwei spaces reformat excellent leute seid
ihr team zwei spaces oder team vier spaces oder seid ihr gar team tap und jeder soll
sich so konfigurieren wie er will eigentlich eigentlich ist das beste wenn man so will
eigentlich ist tap tap sinnvoll ohne mist ich steige jetzt ich steige jetzt auch auf tap
und hab zwei in den size tap one so easy warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht was tap
okay ich lass es ich lass es ich stelle es ich stelle es wieder zurück irgendwie verbackt
hätte eigentlich gedacht man könne es eigentlich eigentlich sind taps taps sind eigentlich
die high q lösung weil jeder machen kann was er will weil jeder sein seine sachen so
formatieren kann wie er will drei spaces wer macht denn so was gibt es wirklich leute
die dreizeits doch das doch jebaited oder wie lief das bewerbungsgespräch ja kam jetzt
schon kam jetzt schon öfters die frage deswegen sage ich jetzt noch mal ich hab jetzt schon
dreimal erzählt lief eigentlich ganz gut ich glaube ich hab es ein bisschen zu sehr
geschockt mit meinem pochen auf 99 prozent home office und vier tage woche letztendlich
ist aber auch vollkommen in ordnung wenn sie das nicht wollen weil man muss sich ja einig
werden also man muss sich ja unterm strich einig werden und ich glaube bei der bei der
gehalsgeschichte haben sie auch geschluckt aber ich will halt nicht weniger verdienen
als vorher aber wie gesagt man muss sich man muss sich einig werden wenn es nicht passt
passt nichts kann man kann man nichts machen ja genug it jobs auf der welt und ich hab
ja auch nicht nötig jetzt gerade weil ich hab ja ich habe den job wäre cool die motivat
also die leute klang mega motiviert was ich so von der aktuellen arbeit gar nicht kenne
aus dem gesichtspunkt fand ich schon sehr nice aber wie gesagt vier tage woche und
mein pochen auf 99 prozent home office ist gleich also ich hab ich hab gesehen die begeisterung
war nicht gerade direkt zu spüren aber was willst du machen was willst du was willst
du tun wie der echte gangster gesagt hätte falls jemand noch den echten gangster kennt
wenn den echten gangster nicht kennt dann kennt ihr bestimmt das german unreal tournament
kit ich will unreal tournament spielen ich will nicht dass es leht weil wenn es leht
dann stürzt es ab oder so ähnlich was willst du tun genau den meine ich german angry kid
der sehr übelst krasse bodybuilder typ ist wenn es leht muss man so lange warten der
typ war seinerzeit der typ war seinerzeit total voraus ja
so also was wir heute versuchen ist diesen komischen amazon haufen an wildem wildem code
den amazon hier fabriziert hat so weit aufzuräumen dass ich das in mein programm einbauen will
ja das ist oh ne ne das will ich hier nicht das ist nämlich das ist wirklich das ist
wirklich wild was amazon hier an manchen stellen verzapft hat und das muss nicht sein guck das
ist viel mehr hier ganz ganz viel zeug immerhin alles gut dokumentiert muss man amazon zugute
halten ist schön beschriftet weiß man überall was sache ist aber schön ist was anderes
ich könnte jetzt einfach einen ordner machen bei mir im projekt und das da reinkopieren
und sagen ja was juckt mich easy gucke ich nie wieder rein aber man könnte ja auch mal
probieren schön zu machen und dazu habe ich was schönes gefunden auf github ein beispiel
wo das jemand von hand implementiert hat da kann man nämlich deutlich besser abgucken
als bei diesem amazon kram ob es funktioniert weiß ich nicht leider gibt es leider gibt
es davon kein nougat package der hat das nachgebaut und leute das ist deutlich kürzer und deutlich
übersichtlicher als das was amazon gebaut hat das heißt das werden wir jetzt auch ausprobieren
ziel ist ich kann es ja noch mal zeigen ich muss mir einen fake account wieder machen
bei fiat wie viele fiat fake account sie schon hatte so muss man password das ist nicht
sieht so in die zwischenablage kopieren einloggen sie haben ihr kennwort ein ich will mich registrieren
ich lösche ja aber meine accounts danach immer bei homeoffice könnt ihr dich zum
beispiel nicht konzentrieren aber überlegt mal wie guckst du jetzt meinen stream wenn
ich homeoffice vorname keckel gut chat ja ja ja so rum ist besser so email also ich kann
mich bei homeoffice deutlich besser konzentrieren als auf der arbeit kennwort wunderbar weiter
ablehnen ablehnen ablehnen ablehnen ablehnen weiter so und jetzt zeige ich euch was das
aussieht was wir eigentlich abgreifen wollen und zwar hier sieht man hier sieht man das guckt
die fiat web services oder die fiat smart car services wie immer das genau heißt die benutzen
amazon mqtt wer sich kennt mqtt ist ein iot message broker also ein sehr leichtgewichtiges
protokoll zum austausch von nachrichten zwischen microcontroller bzw iot devices was in iot
devices das ist eine buzzword für zum beispiel wlan lampe mit wlan oder irgendwie so ein
temperatursensor oder ein fenster auf und zu sensor also internet of things weil es cooler
klingt als microcontroller also zum beispiel so eine led lampe oder sowas die tauschen
gerne information über mqtt aus weil gerade bei iot geräten ist halt batterieverbrauch
wichtig und iot ist halt so leichtgewichtig und klein und minimalistisch das braucht nicht
viel bandbreite was für fiat wahrscheinlich in dem fall auch relevant ist weil sie haben
ja wahrscheinlich nur einen billigen sim iot tarif für ihre autos und das ist natürlich
ein bisschen größer weil sie in web requests verpackt ist aber die verwenden mqtt also
sprich hier die web anwendung hängt jetzt an diesem mqtt bus mein auto beziehungsweise
das auto das account wo man sich einloggt verschickt auch per mqtt messages und zum
beispiel jetzt nur mal so zu erklären weil angenommen das auto fährt jetzt in den eigenen hof und man
hat das auf der karte als gebiet markiert dann würde ich jetzt hier über mqtt eine
nachricht kriegen hallo das auto ist gerade im hof angekommen ja dann wird dann wahrscheinlich
in den bitt gesetzt von 0 auf 1 auf dem passenden channel so sieht es aus und das schöne ist dass
man das abgreifen kann über diesen mqtt broker wenn man das eben mit den passenden zugangsdaten
macht was sehr sehr nice ist weil so kann ich das in meine konto verifizieren bei uconnect
services nicht aber so kann ich das mit mitschneiden und in meine smart home sache integrieren also wie
gesagt ich kann mich bei home office viel viel viel viel viel viel besser konzentrieren als auf der
arbeit was dann darauf liegt was oftmals darauf rausläuft dass ich auf der arbeit kaum was
zustande bekomme im home office die sachen wieder aufhole deswegen sage ich ja 100 prozent home
office ist bei mir das beste was es gibt eigentlich nur für mich und den arbeitgeber von vorteil aber
das verstehen unsere boomer management nicht so richtig die sagen sich wenn ich den nicht
täglich über den über die schulter gucken kann dann wollen die nicht machen die nix oder was auch
immer keine ahnung keine ahnung ob wir so scharf drauf sind ich weiß es nicht mir auch egal sobald
ich was anderes finde bin ich weg im home office bist du produktive ja ist bei mir genauso aber es
ist sicherlich so ein bisschen persönliche sache von den leuten also es gibt bestimmt leute die
kommen so besser klar und leute die andersweilig besser klarkommen also home office oder vor Ort
ich bin der meinung das soll man einfach den leuten so ermöglichen wie es für sie am besten
ist weil letztendlich ist das was für die leute am besten ist meistens auch produktivität technisch
und für den arbeitgeber am besten das heißt warum machen sie eigentlich so großen akt ja
weil weil weißt du warum weil führungsetage oftmals bisschen outdated overrated gebated
wann kommt der nächste genshin content es gibt 19 gibt es ein sponsored video allerdings nicht
genshin sondern einen gaming tisch gaming den nicht gaming tisch ein gaming gaming möbel gaming
equipment gibt es dann diesmal sogar wird das ganze sogar von einem echten kameramann gefilmt
stellt euch das mal vor richtig richtig nice kamerafahrt von vom schreibtisch gibt es dann
mit rgb und allem schon abgefilmt nee nee nee es läuft gerade wird gerade gefilmt
und ich darf dann halb technisch was drüber labern und ich habe ihnen auch die erlaubnis
gegeben dass sie das als werbung auf ihrer home page stand verwenden dürfen ich war
gespannt stelle ich stelle euch mal vor ihr kommt random auf irgendeine home page dann
erzählt euch der max wie geil als auf einmal der tisch ist
most game changing desk of my life das wäre das wäre eine level cap in den level cap titel
ok leute wir wollten ja eigentlich was was was bauen also das wollen wir abgreifen so
das haben wir das letzte mal auch gebaut
lull alter keckel so siehts aus das haben wir das letzte mal auch gebaut das dumme dabei
war nur wir haben ganz viel legacy amazon viren code und das versuchen wir mal bisschen schöner
zu machen ich muss mich einmalig einloggen auf der konsole hier jetzt export das ist
falsch export muss die neue email adresse rein für den fake account und chat jetzt
müssen wir mal gucken wie wir das machen
wie kriege ich jetzt also ich habe jetzt zwei möglichkeiten entweder ich gebe das password
auf der konsole ein und ihr macht alle die augen zu oder ich mache den bildschirm aus
oder ich lese das irgendwie über die shell ein ohne dass es in der history steht
wir machen wir machen das anders wir sagen riet riet so riet keckel ah moment riet minus
s ist es glaube ich keckel ok und jetzt ist echo reply ok so funktioniert das also so
machen wir das jetzt echo riet minus s so und da kann ich jetzt das password eingeben
ich hoffe das funktioniert so wunderbar da ist hat funktioniert schauen wir mal ob das
mit den warum geht es nicht hier ach ich bin ja auch doof leute muss das ganze nochmal
machen lull das da guck mal guck mal wie blöd ich bin hier muss das plötzlich da reply
muss da rein dollar reply muss da rein und hier muss jetzt riet minus s machen so ich
hoffe das funktioniert jetzt
tu drachenflieger hey es funs nice ne reply reply macht standardmäßig reply macht standardmäßig
in also riet liest dies standardmäßig in reply wenn du keine variabler eingibst ok
hat funktioniert so da können wir uns jetzt hier nämlich die die keys rausholen und dann
wieder anfangen zu basteln ja ist so so wir machen mal ein extra aws tests aws test mqtt
genau so und hier kopieren wir uns den kram hin ex ist trocken gut das ist die adresse
das ist nach wie vor richtig und jetzt versuchen wir uns mal zu amazon zum amazon mqtt server
zu verbinden das steht nicht in der man page ja weiß nicht ist aber so secret knowledge
das ist immer hat sich wieder gelohnt dass man im stream dabei ist sagt doch gleich
leute gleich bei euch zeiterfassung aufmachen eintragen fortbildung auf geht's also ziel
ist dass wir uns jetzt jetzt auf jetzt auf schön zu amazon verbinden auf nicht schön
haben wir es hier gemacht ok also das da kopieren wir uns mal rüber
das werden wir auf jeden fall brauchen das da brauchen wir auf jeden fall nicht mehr
das da brauchen wir auch nicht mehr und das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr im prinzip
hätte ich mir das rüber kopieren auch sparen können wenn ich alles davon lösche so host
region access key secret key token alles klar ja dann schauen wir doch erstmal ob ich so
eine richtig ob ich die url richtig generieren kann wie ich mich zu amazon verbinden will
also new aws mqtt connection so host ist das da
host ist das da region ist das das ist halt ein bisschen bescheuert das muss man wissen
bei aws heißen die dinger halt so eu west eins das wollen sie halt so access key moins
serious max auch am start dachte du bist arbeiten access key token ne wir machen das anders
secret key kommt zuerst secret key ist der da und tauchen ist dieses lange ding hier
gatschi bass so ops jetzt hab ich vertippt new war so also das sind unsere zugangsdaten
für amazon und jetzt kann ich daraus eine url generieren die ich brauche mich zu connecten
wichtig ist diese amazon iot mqtt server läuft über web sockets das heißt es muss am ende
auf jeden fall irgendwas mit wss doppel punkt doppel slash am anfang kommen sein request
wunderbar also es muss auf jeden fall sowas da raus kommen am ende hier sowas muss da
rauskommen guckt das können wir uns tatsächlich auch kopieren machen wir das mal so url ich
hab das schon kopiert hier websockets secure websockets host das was wir da oben eingetragen
haben also hier den da aws aha wx px jb 5 ck g1 minus ats obvius leute oder dass das
so heißt wie sollte es auch anders heißen vollkommen klar iot eu west amazon aws.com
hier eingesetzt port 443 und pass slash mqtt das sieht man übrigens auch hier wenn man
sich den request anguckt im browser guckt da request host schema wss und feilen im mqtt
also im prinzip die url so wie man es zusammengesetzt hat wenn wir das jetzt laufen lassen wird
man wahrscheinlich feststellen dass nicht stimmt was da rauskommt warum habe ich überhaupt
dieses komische zeug mit kill hintendran braucht keiner so funktioniert nicht weil gibt kommt
nix bei raus endpoint absolut so ok gut ersetzt das richtig zusammen also was am ende rauskommen
soll ist eine url wo ich mich per mqtt über websockets zur amazon verbinden kann diese
url muss beinhalten einmal natürlich die richtige adresse dann diesen parameter diesen parameter
diesen parameter diesen parameter diesen und diesen parameter und exakt so wie es hier
geschrieben ist mit exakt den werten die hier drinne stehen also außer die variablen werte
die die ändern sich aber so muss der request aussehen das heißt ein korrekter request
sieht so aus ich gebe zu super lesbar das ganze so sieht ein korrekter request aus damit
man sich verbinden kann zu amazon es muss irgendwie den algoritmus enthalten den man
zum signing verwendet irgendeinen credentials key url encoded mit der region und dem iot
bis gateway aws 4 request obviously was auch immer muss halt so sein dann muss das datum
in zeit in utc dann welche header in diesem request gesetzt sind das ist nur der host
header und dann das security talking und die signature am ende die signature ist tatsächlich
das komplizierteste an der ganzen geschichte weil die signature müssen wir irgendwie berechnen
und wenn ich das da habe diesen string dann kann ich in mqtt klein nehmen und mich dahin
verbinden aber erst einmal müssen wir gucken dass wir diesen string irgendwie zusammen
gebaut bekommen wir haben hier ein beispiel wie es funktioniert das haben wir das letzte
mal im stream ja gemacht das hat auch funktioniert oder wir haben zur abwechslung hier ein beispiel
wo es eine etwas übersichtlicher gemacht hat wie das ganze klappt ich finde ich finde
das hier deutlich deutlich besser lesbar als das was amazon fabriziert hat ok also fangen
wir mal an wir brauchen lasst mal kurz überlegen wir brauchen als erstes nicht nur die url
sondern den query parameter very parameter ist das ding hinten dran an urls moment das
da guckt hier query parameter also alles hinter dem fragezeichen also das was ihr vielleicht
von webseiten kennt hier also benutzen heute wenige webseiten noch hier guckt mal so was
hier zum beispiel das hier ist da das hier sind query parameter das hier ist das hier
ist die die url mit fad hier dazwischen kann alternativ noch ein port sein da und das hier
ist quasi der also das ist der query parameter das ist quasi so eine art variable die man
setzen kann in der url machen man heute verhältnismäßig wenig tatsächlich hauptsächlich
für für so suche und sonst was früher in php haben die leute quasi alles über irgendwelche
url parameter gemacht das war halt abfuck da waren auch session tokens und alles mögliche
einfach so in klartext in der url das hat damals kein interessiert heute ist man da
etwas kritischer geworden dass es keine so gute idee ist heute schickt man das meistens
als post request im body das macht zwar nicht weniger abhör sicher aber das handling macht
deutlich sicherer und einfacher aber man muss das für mqtt eben in diesem in dem query
parameter übergeben das heißt dieses ding müssen wir uns hier irgendwie zusammen bauen
das wird was ok also wo fangen wir an wir haben die url haben wir schon mal da müssen
jetzt die ganzen query parameter dran das heißt ich muss mir erstmal raussuchen in
dem eigentlichen code von amazon was die denn da jetzt eigentlich genau machen also das
ganze geht an iot device gateway ok was was machen sie denn hier request datetime datetime
stamp das kopiere ich mir mal rüber das brauchen wir auf jeden fall was das iso 8601 basic format
alles klar kopieren das einfach mal rüber so datetime stamp gibt es von amazon headers
contain host das muss ich nicht machen meine request headers enthalten auf jeden fall host
nee ich habe ja kein request aber mal gucken mal gucken die preise von online shops in
query parameter leute das haben die früher gemacht zum glück hat es neverando nie gemacht
mal auf krasse krasse hacker action leute guckt mal hier ach mist ich wollte eigentlich ok
es ist jetzt hier eigentlich wollte ich nur einen dummen witz machen ich wollte eigentlich
sagen hier guckt mal richtig krasse hacker schitten dem ich hier im source code jetzt
den preis endet aber massive weil das wird manchmal in videos auf youtube gezeigt und
die immer so als sind sie die mega heftigen hacker märz weil sie kleinzeitig in den text
geändert haben wo ich mir dann auch immer denke ja und weiter das frist das shop doch
gar nicht an der stelle sollte zumindest nicht dem html schon mal gar nicht sondern das
müsste sein in einem form request ändern wenn überhaupt zu uns in frankfurt zum glück
nicht direkt in frankfurt aber ich arbeite direkt in frankfurt sogar in der nähe vom
hauptbahnhof frankfurt goethe straße goethe straße louis vitor store zahlt die kollektion
bar fick auf sponsor sagt haftbefehl ob das so ist kann ich nicht beurteilen so jetzt
immer ganz schön weit im bogen gespannt oder von amazon mqtt zu haftbefehl hat er sich
ein ist sein bein eigentlich wieder geheilt der hat sich doch letztens aus versehen ins
bein geschossen jeden morgen ein frankfurter ruhig am bahnhof leute ich ich gehe ungern
zum frankfurter bahnhof ist so letztens wieder vorbeigelaufen auf dem heimweg normalerweise
laufe ich immer zum südbahnhof als angenehmer ist aber letztens wieder zum hauptbahnhof
die leute da meine güne es ist so ein dreckes laufe von hauptbahnhof so schlimm so eklig
so abwartig erstmal ok bei der gelegenheit muss ich immer die gleiche story erzählen
ich weiß recycle story aber ich war mal blut abnehmen bei meinem hausarzt und da hat mich
die die auszubildende gefragt beziehungsweise die die arzthelferin hat mich gefragt ob die
auszubildende das machen darf ja und natürlich wenn er da als kell vor zwei medel sitzt willst
jetzt nicht da übelst als weichei rüberkommen das nach klar lasse ich das bei mir machen
ja und habe ich dann habe ich dann so gesagt natürlich kann sie an mir üben arm hin asubi
sticht rein nimmt mir blut ab und beim rausziehen verdreht sie oder verkantet sie irgendwie
die nadel und drückt nicht richtig drauf tut mega weh schon beim nadel rausziehen und
einen halben tag später habe ich kompletten blut erguss quasi so von der tja ist arm
beuge halt von dort wo die adern lang laufen zu den kompletten armen zu den kompletten
unter armen runter so am anderen tag fahre ich nach frankfurt lauf bei den ganzen assis
vorbei und irgendwie also auch bei den ganz drogenabhängigen und irgendwie sind die super
nett zu mir und begrüßen mich und so das machen die nie normalerweise will ich nichts
von denen wissen und die nicht von mir und die manche leute sitzen also rums so hallo
und ich denke mir so was zum teufel ist hier los bis ich bis mir es dann gedämmert ist
die haben gedacht ich bin einer von ihnen wegen dem armen von uns die haben gedacht
vielleicht habe ich noch ein bisschen was übrig und wenn ich nett bin wenn die netz
zu mir sind dann kriegen sie noch was ab das habe ich aber erst später gecheckt schon
seitdem der arm wieder normales sagt keiner was und ich auch nicht so ist es halt frankfurt
was willst du machen könnte man eigentlich für ein video oder in einem highlight zusammenschnitt
wieder machen was ein paar sachen muss ja mein kater braucht was zu tun leute ich sehe
schon wir kommen heute nicht so wir kommen nicht zu potter mit amazon zeicher aber noch
eineinhalb stunden zeit wie war das gespräch ach so eigentlich ganz gut ich habe es jetzt
schon ein paar mal erzählt aber ich finde ich finde es sehr nett von euch chat dass
ihr da so interessiert dran seid ja gespräch war nicht schlecht ich glaube ich habe zwei
sachen gesagt die sie ein bisschen geschockt haben nämlich einmal dass ich so sehr auf
home office bestehe und dass ich nur vier tage die woche arbeiten gehe weil ich mich
sonst um eine quasi meine firma kümmere das hat sie etwas unvorbereitet getroffen dass
es ja dass es nahezu alles home office ist war ja im vorfeld schon im gespräch aber
dass ich halt auch das so haben will und nicht so mit schwammlichen aussagen leben kann ist
auch ein bisschen unwohl sein gestoßen aber auf der anderen seite ist es ja gut wenn man
das früh merkt oder einfach feststellt das klappt nicht weil naja home office ist für
mich das wichtigste thema auch das wichtigste thema warum ich den job wechseln will das
heißt wenn ich dann quasi zwei stunden anstatt eine stunde fahren muss dann habe ich ja nichts
gewonnen ja okay die die gehalsvorstellung ich meine ich habe halt das gesagt was ich
jetzt auch verdiene plus ein bisschen was ja das hat auch als ich glaube auch ein bisschen
geschockt wobei ich bin nicht ganz sicher bin ob jetzt denken dass es für fünf tage oder
für vier tage war ich weil ich habe meine gehalsvorstellung für fünf tage gesagt habe
ich eigentlich auch erwähnt aber vielleicht ist es untergegangen wie gesagt war okay war
gut an sich als die motivation der leute ist auch wirklich rüber gekommen also ich glaube
wirklich dass die dass es ein cooler land ist aber wie gesagt so was teilzeit und home
office angeht ist es wahnsinnig so ganz glücklich habe ich den eindruck aber kann man halt nichts
machen das ist halt die punkte die mir eben besonders wichtig sind und wenn es halt da
nicht passt da nicht gibt noch genug andere jt jobs und ich bin jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
darauf angewiesen dass ich was neues finde an sich war gut also fachlich und sogar kein
ding passt eigentlich wie die faust aufs auge passt ziemlich gut schauen wir mal aber leute
ich habe noch eineinhalb stunden zeit wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen weitermachen mit amazon
also ein bisschen ordentlicher wird ok also wie geht es wie geht es dann mal wir gucken
uns mal das beispiel von dem typ hier an also was macht der denn hier get sein url oder
uri für was steht das i das l weiß ich url steht für uniform oder unified resource location
oder sowas und was und was ist uri also wahrscheinlich umgangssprachlich das gleiche aber im detail
doch wieder nicht das gleiche auf da ist das nicht gesund tja gut da kann ich ja nichts
für dass du 24 7 daheim warst und ich deswegen kein homeoffice machen machen soll also wenn
du festgestellt hast dass es für dich nichts ist ist ja das eine für mich ist es das beste
was es gibt nicht 24 7 zu hause hocken aber 100 prozent homeoffice zu haben allein schon
dass ich nicht mehr auf die bahn angewiesen bin und ich gehe ja so auch ins freie auch
wenn ich auch wenn ich 100 prozent homeoffice habe 100 prozent homeoffice heißt ja nicht
100 prozent daheim zwangsläufig also du hast natürlich recht 24 7 zu hause ist nicht gesund
wenn du für dich festgestellt hast das ist nichts ist ja vollkommen ok aber wie gesagt
also für mich ist das 100 ist 100 prozent homeoffice das beste was es gibt
echt kannst du dabei entspannen ich bin auch pausenlos am schwätzen quasi hintergrund
rauschen was man so im freien macht zum beispiel ich gehe jetzt gleich noch zwei stunden wandern
bei uns hier irgendwo in der gegend so um 15 uhr und ich hoffe dass ich vorher noch ein
bisschen amazon zeug hinbekomme ok also was macht der typische utc now universal time
method get das haben wir alles service iot service credential scope aha hier kommen da
sache näher also was müssen wir hier machen string builder canonical query string string
bilder ach hier guck mal hier hängt er die ganzen parameter an das kann man doch schöner
machen als mit nem query bilder oder da ist auch bestimmt irgendwas framework technisch
eingebaut ist eingebaut um das um so was zu machen canonical request ok das brauchen wir
auf jeden fall gleich schau mal wie amazon das selbst gemacht hat schau mal wie amazon
das selbst macht hier weil da ist aber so das hier ist das offizielle amazon beispiel
dafür beziehungsweise die das offizielle sample wie man das internet macht also erste mal
bauen sie einen scope zusammen das müssen wahrscheinlich auch machen einen date stamp
ich glaube die katze ist an der tür wartet mal kurz so katze hat doch keinen bock haben
gebockt bock reinzukommen stehen geblieben also wir brauchen anscheinend noch einen date
stamp warum auch immer ein date timestamp reicht nicht wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch
ein date stamp date stamp format natürlich amazon in einem anderen format wie date ich
hätte er fragt das gar nicht wir gucken uns das einfach ab dann brauchen wir noch einen
scope einen scope ist ein was ein date stamp die region der service und ein terminator
ok das werden wir etwas entwirren dass man das auch gescheit lesen kann wir machen erst
mal da ein template string draus und nicht so komisches ding erste mal so region service
ist iot wie war da wie war das service iot device irgendetwas iot device gateway clipboard
manager beste und einen terminator der terminator ist was
aws 4 request da sieht man hier unten auch irgendwo kommt mal das sieht man hier auch
hier irgendwo da hier aws 4 request alles klar jetzt wissen wir bescheid so übrigens
blödsinn hier muss iot device gateway hin hier muss aws aws request rein kann man sich
das hier hinten nämlich alle sparen das kommt weg und das format kommt auch weg und schon
ist das ganze wieder deutlich lesbarer tips und projekte für zu hause zu finden ja irgendwas
machen was interessiert genau genau im prinzip das was chillfreak sagt ja so siehts aus
so so ist es so ist es leute und wenn du irgendwas hast was sie stört beziehungsweise was du
gerne machen willst dann musst du die passende technologie dafür suchen und dann loslegen
gibt ja unterschiedlichefelder ja das kann sein dass du heim automatisierungs was machen
willst vielleicht willst du eine webseite machen alles mögliche amthaft irgendwas suchen
ist meistens keine so gute idee so jetzt haben wir den scope das da brauchen wir schon mal
nicht haben wir den scope was auch immer mit dem scope jetzt machen was machen wir mit
dem scope jetzt adder brauchen wir nicht parameter brauchen wir nicht aha jetzt brauchen wir
die parameter dafür ok also wir brauchen amazon algorithm in der reinfolge auch das
weiß ich amazon möchte dass die header in der richtigen reinfolge sind beziehungsweise
die parameter in der richtigen reinfolge sind das heißt amazon macht das übrigens in ihrem
eigenen beispiel falsch die müssen alphabetisch geordnet sein diese parameter sonst frisst
die amazon nicht dementsprechend müsste date for signed headers kommen aber da hat sich
wahrscheinlich amazon gedacht wen juckts wir können auch unsere beispiele falsch machen
wie kriege ich denn das da jetzt angehängt endpoint bilder query add ne wie hängt man
da was ist heute nicht dein probertag ne heute hatte ich vorstellungsgespräch wie hängt
wie baut man da jetzt ein query draus zusammen ich verwende die eingebauten framework sachen
so selten dafür also gerade gerade für für url building verwende ich eigentlich immer
flurrl das ist deutlich einfach wie macht man das jetzt query stack overflow fragen
macht es das query bilder c-sharp nicht query sowas how to build a url query string best
way to a panel aha aha aha ok nice what query heart ttp utility pass curry string string
empty what das sieht aber nach ganz schön großer magic aus uri bilder weil die mir
erzählen die haben keinen gescheiten query string bilder in dotnet drinnen for those
who do not want to include system web form url encoded content also jetzt wird es aber
abgedreht was also ich will einfach query dinger zusammen bauen es kann doch nicht
sein dass da nix im framework drin ist was gescheit funktioniert was was genau macht
der duta was was was was bin ich hier überhaupt sehen das ist ja so schlecht formatiert ok
das sieht schon besser aus das gibt es nur als das kann doch nicht sein dass man so sich
die die die quette das query zusammen bauen muss oder der eichler dankeschön für den
zapp das kann doch nicht sein dass man sich das so zusammenbauen probieren das mal aus
also amazon algorithm brauchen wir amazon credentials brauchen wir mal ob das funktioniert was
was deck overflow ich weiß ja das deck overflow im prinzip immer funktioniert weil es ist
der overflow die frage ist natürlich die ich bis heute nicht beantworten konnte wie
konnte stack overflow ohne stack overflow erschaffen werden versteht das irgendjemand
das ist eigentlich eigentlich geht das nicht wir haben die das wir haben das geschafft
ja das stehe ich auch nicht so probieren wir mal gucken was da jetzt rauskommt lullwee ok
und point uri bilder können wir das ding einfach so nennen so und jetzt zeigt mal hier ob
da jetzt was sinnvolles bei rauskommt ob das was sinnvolles bei rauskommt man mal das sieht
doch gar nicht mal so schlecht was ist das dann für das ist ja die ekligste art und
weiß sich nur ull zusammen zu bauen nicht mir nur denken kann monka es alter ist das
hässlich gibt es ja echt nichts besseres im framework als diesen rotz das ist ja mal
total abartig guckt euch das mal an das kannst doch keinem zeigen aber zumindest ja genau
das verwende ich nämlich normalerweise auch aber das will ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als
dependent sie jetzt an der stelle haben die haben keinen gescheiten query bilder wirklich
nett ja flur ja super das verwende ich ja normalerweise auch so aber das ist ja schon
abartig dass sowas da nicht drin ist ok dann meinetwegen so form ul encoded content so
amazon algorithm was muss da rein aws minus das da einfach nur aws oder aws 4 aws 4 ok
aws 4 minus das da credentials was muss da rein ähm ah moment das muss alles ul encoded
fern hat das ist die frage ul encoded das oder nicht können wir ganz einfach testen
das ul encoded auch schon sehr sehr nice prog würde ich sagen das ul encoded auch schon
das heißt man kann das so nehmen das heißt wir brauchen wirklich nur das da so aws key
this xs key und dann der scope so das machen wir wieder so als template wir brauchen da
kein format das ist ja komplett outdated overrated das benutzt ja keiner mehr so so ah sieht
doch schon besser aus warum kann er das nicht zumachen die klammer moment die klammer macht
er doch so alles gut hallo ich will es reformaten please reformat so das haben wir jetzt sieben
acht amazon date date muss was sein date date timestamp ul encoded date timestamp ul encoded
haben wir gut und sein header muss ich den kram berechnen schauen wir mal ob das so weit
funktioniert alles hey das sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus kommt mal hier das ist alles
encoded die das datum und so scheint auch zu stimmen gut der header stimmt halt nicht so
jetzt muss ich das seinen wie man auch immer das sein wir gleich noch mal rauskriegen da
braucht man den amazon package mit irgendeinem amazon signing algorithmus einbinden und nachdem
wir das gesenkt haben die moment sein tätors sein tätors ist host ist ja nur ein host header
drinne jetzt muss ich das seinen und dann muss ich wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe am ende
muss ich noch amazon security talken und amazon signature anhängen meine güte ist das komplizierter
kram willst du von local mqtt auf host mqtt umsteigen ne aber fiat benutzt das fiat benutzt
amazon aws mqtt und das will ich abgreifen und jetzt muss ich so tun als bin ich ein
fiat amazon aws client beziehungsweise bin ich als bin ich ein aws client der mqtt spricht
so signature das muss ich hier an an die url hinten anhängen glaube so seinen jetzt
also hier muss ich muss ich seinen das muss ich auch auskriegen wie ich das mache und dann
sagen wir content ad was hättest kann man da nix hinzufügen es ist ja der schlechteste
querys durch bilder den ich jemals gesehen hat man oder sind das hier die headers
das ist ja wirklich mies also das ist da nichts besseres im framework gibt es wirklich ganz
ganz wild tauchen muss da rein ok tauchen alles klar und jetzt brauchen noch x amazon
signature und da kommt das ja war ja hasch was auch immer wie auch immer man das jetzt
berechnet rein wenn ich das gemacht habe so und dann sollte jetzt was sinnvolles bei
rauskommen das hat nicht funktioniert den schlechteste den ich bis jetzt gesehen habe
ist richtig also anscheinend hat es so mit dem hinzufügen nicht was zum name value das
kann doch nicht sein gibt es da wirklich nichts gibt es da wirklich nichts gescheites im framework
um querys zu bilden das ist doch wirklich lächerlich form data collection ist das eine
form data collection die ich hier habe form data collection gibt es überhaupt nicht stack
overflow kackel pass das hier zeigt mal kürbler oh ja das ist gut ane das ist nur für web
für webprojekte das gibt es im normalen projekt nicht query bilder das geht nur wenn
es ein webprojekt ist und das komplette asp.net core als dependency drin ist tja microsoft
geschissen warum ist denn sowas nicht im standard standard library drin es ist ja ist ja reudig
wie man so schön sagt wo kommt eigentlich der secret key jetzt mal zum einsatz wo verwenden
die denn den secret key secret beim seinen dann später ok das ist natürlich das natürlich
echt bescheuert ok dann dann ist das hier in den dictionary das ist nett lul weh man
ok jetzt wird es jetzt wird es hässlich jetzt wird es hässlich aber es sollte funktionieren
so query string kommt jetzt was gescheites bei raus hey guck mal da nice es funktioniert
ich mein da fehlt das wichtigste noch nämlich die signatur aber das sieht doch jetzt schon
ungefähr nach diesem query string aus den wir brauchen nice so nice so nice so gut zwar
nicht schön aber schöner als der kram von amazon ist es wie kriegen wir das jetzt wie
kriegen wir jetzt diese signature ist signature gebaut hier signature string to hex string
ne ne da muss es was fertiges von amazon geben lasst mich mal kurz in meine magick magick
dokument zum abgucken spicken weil da habe ich mir nämlich schon was raus kopiert was
man hier verwendet guckt ich verwende hier schon so amazon signatur zeug und zwar da
wo aws amazon ne wo ist es denn jetzt aber falsch nicht programm helfer helfer ja da
seiner ane das ist so ein zusatzding das habe ich ja hier nicht aber ich habe trotzdem
was und zwar gibt es ein aws for seiner wo gibt es das das habe ich schon mal verwendet
das ist in das ist hier in dem github projekt drinne in welchem nur get package ist in der
aws sdk core das klingt auch schon mal gut ja wenn man wenn man aws verwenden will dass
man dann irgendwie aws dependency braucht da wundert es wundert mich nett und jetzt
gibt es hier drinne compute signature sehr schön genau das was wir brauchen weil ganz
ernst im ernst den kram den die hier gebaut haben den will ich nicht von hand bauen müssen
ok so wie wie berechnen wir davon jetzt ordentlich was compute signature credentials brauchen
wir erst mal das ist relativ easy new credentials da kommt der key rein da kommt das secret rein
und da kommt das token rein ok next region haben wir auch next datetime utc now weil
amazon es halt so haben will service das kennen wir auch das ist diese iot gateway so und
jetzt kommt signed headers host ist der einzige header den wir drinne haben so und jetzt wird
es lustig den habe ich nämlich nicht jetzt braucht man hier einen einen canonical request
den habe ich nicht den müssen wir uns jetzt von hier abgucken wie die das gebaut haben
ob es am ende funktioniert ist mal was ganz was anderes so das hier guckt das brauchen
wir jetzt das was dieser dude hier gebaut hat oder alternativ wir gucken uns ab wie
es amazon selbst gemacht hat canonical request ok wir gucken sonst von amazon selbst ab wir
gucken wobei wir machen es ganz einfach guck mal wir lassen uns das einfach ausgeben wir
machen einfach einen print drunter und lassen uns das hier ausgeben und gucken mal was der
für ein request schickt so so muss der request am ende aussehen get mqtt dann die ganzen
parameter dann der host header und dann ein leerzeichen ach du scheiße haben die sich
denn da wieder ausgedacht bei emerson ok ich copy paste mir das mal kurz das müssen wir
zusammen bauen also canonical requests http methode ist get können wir schon mal weg machen
get und einfach nur append ohne format get all endpoint einfach nur was wir hier gerade
gesehen haben einfach nur slash mqtt machen wir auch einfach append was wir machen der
das hier hier slash mqtt wobei wir könnten auch dass es allgemeingültige ist vielleicht
sagen uri oder url und dann path es müsste das gleiche sein query parameters query parameters
ist das hier dann kommen headers headers ist quasi nur host die header names ist nur host
da kommen jetzt die richtigen die richtigen header das muss dann so so irgendwie aussehen
ja gut also im endeffekt muss das aussehen nach host doppelpunkt und da muss dann also
leute nicht dass ihr denkt ich hätte irgendwie eine ahnung was ich hier mache ich versuche
das einfach nur mal abzutippen ich bin im fall null für den falschen falschen editor
drinne habe ich jetzt überall falsch gemacht habe ich das jetzt also das müssen host doppelpunkt
was wird gemacht wir versuchen uns zu amazon iot zu verbinden und zwar so dass man am ende
auch noch versteht nicht wie das amazon beispiel url und jetzt wahrscheinlich query und jetzt
host und jetzt irgendeinen hasch da weiß ich nicht wie man den hasch compute schau
man mal jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was was da jetzt rauskommt wir können es ja direkt
vergleichen mit dem anderen wo es funktioniert das ist für mich ganz praktisch dann kann
man nämlich direkt sehen ob es geht oder nicht so guck es ist doppelt das ist auch nicht
query es ist host ja das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus hier bla bla bla signage hey
das sieht relativ gut aus guck mal so so muss es aussehen so muss es aussehen und so sieht
es aktuell aus das gar nicht mal so verkehrt warte mal ich versuche das mal irgendwie so
ungefähr ungefähr auf die gleiche höhe zu schieben so das gett ist um geil lull gett
gett ist um guck mal so sieht es aus und so soll es aussehen das ist relativ gut das
einzige was fehlt ist da ist ein leerzeichen zwischen diesem host und dem anderen guck
mal ansonsten ist es mehr oder weniger doch alles das gleiche moment da fehlt was da fehlt
mqtt dazwischen bin ich verwirrt habe ich das da nicht url pass habe ich doch da fehlt
das new line da fehlt das new line hinten dran ok ok so ist gut mit nem slash davor
ok weißt du was scheiß drauf wir schreiben das da hardcoded rein slash mqtt so und wir
brauchen hier davor brauchten wir einfach zwei hier müssen zwei leerzeichen sein so
das sieht gut aus guck mal das ist exakt das gleiche schaut mal was ist also ich kann
nicht scrollen man das ist exakt das gleiche hier guck mal also ich rede nur von den oberen
paar zeilen das ist genau das gleiche aber moment bei dem einen ist noch ein fragezeichen
und bei dem anderen nicht hier bei meinem ist noch ein fragezeichen drin dann schneiden
wir das fragezeichen mal ab ok wir nähern uns der sache wir nähern wir nähern uns der
sache was hängen die dann hier unten noch für eine für eine für einen hash wert an
wo kommt denn der her bodyhash bodyhash empty bodyhash na geil super und was ist das ach
ja obviously einfach einfach magic string irgendwo drin alles gut der muss da anscheinend
rein so so was ist das für ein hash verus total monka ist richtig empty das ist das
vielleicht der hash für einen leeren string wartet mal nach 265 das ist der hash von einem
leeren bodi ach so jetzt verstehe ich das würde man einen request machen wo im body
was steht dann müsste man das schad 256 haschen nachdem im body nichts steht muss man einen
leeren string haschen und den den hash für den leeren string meine güte amazon komplizierter
hätten wir es nicht mehr machen können oder sie schab ist böse bei microsoft aws ist
deutlich schlimmer gerade aber dankeschön für den sub aws macht mich gerade richtig
fertig das ist richtig feifert ende gelände oder wer hat wer hat sich das denn wieder
ausgedacht man egal solange es hardcoded immer der gleiche string ist soll mir das recht
sein aws hat es bei iot etwas versemmelt ich merke es ja so und jetzt und jetzt und jetzt
mal schauen ob das jetzt klappt guck mal jetzt sagen wir hier host und jetzt sagen wir canonical
request to string und jetzt bekommen wir hier einen hash bei raus hoffe ich mal sein oder
so oder ein signing result bekommen wir da raus richtig high q so signing result und
dann signature das ist gut ok so mal schauen was da jetzt rauskommt ja mister toxter wir
werden es nie raus bekommen was du da geschrieben hast so aus das ist was sehr kurzes was man
durchprobieren kann leute das sieht doch jetzt verhältnismäßig gut aus vielleicht ist es
auch gar kein hash vielleicht ist einfach base 64 ja ich werde ich werfe mal kurz meine
passwort mein hash cracker an auf der grafikkarte auf dem zweiten rechner ne mache ich nicht
kostet viel zu viel strom ich habe vorhin von den stadtwerke post bekommen es kostet
jetzt irgendwie statt 23 cent irgendwie 41 cent oder sowas die kilowattstunde ich mach
garantiert kein kein gpu password cracking tool jetzt an bei den strompreisen leute das
sieht doch relativ gut aus guck du mal dieser request hier mit der signature dieser request
verglichen verglichen mit diesem request das sieht tatsächlich so aus als könnte es funktionieren
oder das könnte klappen schauen wir mal schauen ob es geht ok request sonst wie das lassen
wir mal alles drinne bis in die back bis in die back infos wunderbar jetzt probieren wir
ob wir uns mqtt technisch zu amazon verbinden können nicht terminal ich brauche kein terminal
nougat mqtt nett jawoll
wir sind jetzt schon mal 4.1.3 guck mal der hat geste der typ der haut aber releases raus
wie sonst was wir hatten doch letzten schon mal problemen mit der library wisst ihr noch
wo wir einen bug gefunden haben oder typ hat es quasi live gefixt und gepusht während
wir den stream laufen hatten also nicht dass er den stream gesehen hat aber parallel zum
stream wo wir den bug gefunden haben ihn gefixt der will es wissen hier soll mir recht sein
alles alles gut ich mag aktive aktive libraries also was brauchen wir denn jetzt wir brauchen
einen also das hier ist unsere unsere uhr target oder sowas so da brauchen wir ein mqtt
client factory wie legt man noch mal den mqtt client an mqtt client so new factory jetzt
will das aber wissen oder ok dann machen wir jetzt new mqtt factory create client mqtt client
ja wunderbar logger wir wollen hier nichts loggen mqtt client connect nee websockets
websockets wollen wir machen websockets mqtt client connect await und da brauchen wir jetzt
mqtt client options ja ja new client options websocket oh nee nein nein so ging schon mal
net mqtt client options options bilder websocket ah so ging das target boah ey man kann es
einem auch das leben schwer machen so ein logger brauchen wir trotzdem noch ich will
wissen was der mqtt client macht mqtt logger mqtt logger logger event event logger nee
mqtt log event logger ich rate da ja auch bloß gerade jetzt logger new log message plus
gleich dass da und die log message ausgeben log message excellent message perfekt so
und wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe dann sollte er sich aber ja wait task delay
fünf fünf sekunden warten dann sollte er sich jetzt zu aws verbinden aber wahrscheinlich
geht es nicht so einfach oder hängt mir schon ein bisschen lang wo wir nee moment hat es
jetzt funktioniert oder nicht wait a minute ich habe die logger gar nicht eingestellt
ok logger sind die keys in einer nf nicht an der besseren stelle die sind eh noch temporär
wie das geht das geht ein nee oder nee hat er jetzt verbunden authenticate der mqtt client
mit dem server established wie wir haben das perfekt nachgebaut auf anhieb aha da ist
doch irgendein irgendein haken ist da noch so einfach kann das nicht funktionieren wir
können ja mal testen ob es kaputt geht wenn ich was anderes rein wir machen jetzt mal
wir machen jetzt mal die signature kaputt pass mal auf gucken aber mal gucken aber dann
immer noch connected oder ein fehler schmeißt tatsächlich 403 403 bedeutet ist nicht erlaubt
die first try leute packt schon und man muss sagen man kann das jetzt direkt lesen oder
also jetzt mal im ernst leute was ist schöner zu lesen das hier oder oder das hier und
das hier und das hier und das hier was kann ich nicht aussprechen aber schön dass du
dein weg her gefunden hast kennst du jemand gut mit du meinst seri lock nicht veri lock
oder du meinst seri lock desi alles klar desi fiat champ du meinst du meinst du meinst
seri lock oder seri lock ist eine logging library für dort net falls du vielleicht ich mein
mich würd's nicht wundern wenn es nicht auf was geben würde was veri lock heißt lohnt
es sich anzuhören auf jeden fall war heute im vorstellungsgespräch auch thema ob ich
ahnung von anzippen hab anzippen lohnt sich auf jeden fall äußerst pog ok das ist jetzt
viel viel lesbarer leute als dieser crap den in diesem example von amazon drinne ist das
kann man doch jetzt wirklich gut lesen da kann man sich jetzt doch echt nicht beschweren
kann man alles nachvollziehen was hier passiert dem aber noch ein lehrzeichen weg das wäre
vielleicht nicht content sondern ja query parameters oder rams oder so wie auch immer
ja das versteht man also mich schockt immer noch dass kein ordentlicher query bilder in
dort net dabei ist kannst du mal an einem stream oder in einem video ansprechen ich
muss das nicht ansprechen ich hab sogar schon ganze streams damit gemacht muss einfach mal
im archiv gucken da haben wir einige anzippen streams den canonical stream bilder würde
ich noch in eine eigene funktion packen da hast du recht das kann man auch recht gut
machen ja weil man braucht die url man braucht also man braucht den das ziel quasi und die
query parameter das kann man tatsächlich machen das machen wir in ein eigenes war meine eigene
funktion da können wir jetzt mal gucken ob man das ganze re-faktoren kann so archiv ja
guck guck immer schief mal ausrufen zeichnen archiv im chat wo ist es denn hier functions
re-faktor extract this extract method extract method ja name ja aber mal gen ja perfekt
next ähm wo ist es ja gut guck mal schon hamas extracted soll ich soll ich den url bilder
übergeben oder besser neben übergeben die einzelnen parameter das ist klarer hier string
host string query parameter so hier query host dann sagen wir jetzt hier url host url query
und davon dann alles ups alles bis auf das erste zeichen also du kannst zum beispiel
hier gucken archiv punkt archiv punkt tv kannst du alles die komplette streaming history
durchsuchen sucht zum beispiel mal nach ansebel du wirst da einiges finden und jetzt seht
ihr mal wie high iq die mods beziehungsweise maxis archiv gebaut haben seht ihr dass das
was ich im stream sage durchsuchbar ist per volltext suche wisst ihr eigentlich wie krass
high iq das ist was er da gebaut hat dazu haben wir für 200 euro eine cloud kiste gemietet
mit 30 90 rtx und haben per machine learning mein mein gesprochenes transcribed in text
richtig high iq hier high iq weiß ich aber das hier findet guck mal high iq lob an den
serious max vor allem also der hat sich da wirklich viel gedanken und mühe bei also
viel gedanken machen sich mühe beigegeben dass so nice als archiv rauskommt ich hätte
das nie hinbekommen ich hätte schon bei der hälfte wieder aufgehört ihr wisst wie schnell
ich interesse an irgendwelchen projekten verlier ja leute das ist jetzt tatsächlich
ziemlich gut lesbar muss ich sagen ich bin ich bin begeistert also besser besser allemal
als dieser krempel hier vielleicht pusht vielleicht pusht das sogar als als als eigenes
repo weil ich glaube ich bin nicht der einzige der mit dotnet aws mqtt machen will und keiner
checkt so richtig wie es funktioniert weil dieses beispiel hier von amazon ist jetzt auch
alles andere als einfach zu verdauen hätten wir uns das im letzten stream nicht angeguckt
hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gewusst das sehr nice sehr sehr nice gefällt mir so der logger
kann wieder weg wir haben es auf die reihe gekriegt easy verbunden man könnte man könnte
noch eine extra man könnte noch irgendwie eine extra klasse machen zum beispiel für
diesen amazon aws client aber ganz ehrlich wozu warum den stringbinder nicht komplett
ersetzt und einfach string interpolation da hast du recht eigentlich ist es komplett
unsinnig wartet mal leute das probieren wir jetzt wir können jetzt ein neues c-sharp elf
feature verwenden falls wir das eingestellt haben latest ja wunderbar wir brauchen den
stringbinder eigentlich gar nicht guck mal wir können jetzt nämlich hier request so guck
du mal mal schauen ob das funktioniert war ich da als bauer so sollte es sollte einfach
was hat er für schmerzen was language ist nie ich habe die released dotnet version keck
nämlich für apple rider hat es bloß noch nicht gecheckt dass ich das da ich das habe
weil dort net elf dotnet sieben mit c-sharp elf ist ja schon raus ja das müsste eigentlich
gehen also get slash mqtt ich bin mir gar nicht sicher nee nee nee nee so müsste ich
das wahrscheinlich machen sonst sonst trägt er da in den mist ein slash mqtt ach ja wir
müssen ja noch escape bar das ganze machen query host doppelpunkt host new line new
line host und in der letzten dass er wollte ich habe ich irgendwas übersehen oder müsste
das so funktionieren ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie er hier vorne mit umgeht ob das
dann ob das dann passt schauen wir mal request ja so wird tatsächlich noch besser oh cannot
implicit was ja gut wir brauchen ja auch kein string bilder einfach ein string gutes von
jetzt nicht wahrscheinlich weil zu viele das leerzeichen das sollte da nicht sein
was da jetzt der unterschied dazwischen ok wie die wir machen mal die ausgabe von
beidem was ist jetzt der unterschied muss noch hoch da ist ein u-line dazwischen genau
jaja das wird sein hier war mal request request versus can only kill links da to string das
mal kurz gucken ja ne wo ist denn jetzt genau der unterschied
bestes d-bar gegen pritt leyen obs
ich jetzt blöd ich sehe da kein unterschied guck mal du du du du du du du du du du du
du ich sehe da kein unterschied wo ist dein unterschied wer findet den unterschied no
da zwischen und dazwischen nun ich glaube das ist mal meine maxze
Kannst du nicht string compare machen?
Doch, das ist aber höchstwahrscheinlich false.
Können wir machen.
Das ist schon höchstwahrscheinlich false, aber ich weiß nicht an welcher Stelle es lebt.
Leerzeichen irgendwo, ja wahrscheinlich.
Es ist false, guck.
So, Leerzeichen, kein Leerzeichen.
Kein Leerzeichen, kein Leerzeichen, kein Leerzeichen, kein Leerzeichen.
Eigentlich auch kein Leerzeichen, sondern einfach nur eine neue, neue Zeile.
Da ist ein Leerzeichen dahinter gewesen, okay.
Nope, false, so einfach ist es dann noch nicht.
Wir machen jetzt mal ein diff.
Gibt es wo ein C sharp String diff, gibt es da irgendwas dafür?
Irgendeine fertige String Library oder so?
Ich will so ein diff Highlight, okay, ich weiß, wie wir es machen, File, machen wir
es jetzt so, save, ne, ne, File, Write, All Text in Builder.txt und dann machen wir ein
diff drüber.
Es interessiert mich wirklich, wo da, ja das ist nicht Builder, sondern das ist ja Request.txt,
Request.txt.
Wait a minute, Chat, das müsste eigentlich jetzt funktionieren, warum geht das jetzt
gerade nicht?
Kann es sein, dass meine Talkens ausgelaufen sind?
Leute, ich glaube es geht alles, meine Talkens sind einfach nur ausgelaufen.
Wäre das, wäre das möglich?
Hast du keinen Debugger?
So was machen wir hier nicht, Debugger, keck, was kommt da als nächstes, Tests oder was?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, aber ich glaube, mir fällt auch kein Debugger ein, wo ich Stringdiffs
irgendwie machen könnte.
Ich glaube unsere Credentials sind, ich returne den String Builder, das ist eigentlich nicht
schlimm.
Der wird, der wird zu einem String konvertiert, ich meine wir können, hier mache ich 2 Stringen,
das passt schon.
Also es ist schon mal komisch, dass die Dinger Fault sind, aber wir machen es hier gerade
nochmal kurz.
Ich glaube einfach, meine Keys sind abgelaufen, ich glaube meine Keys sind abgelaufen.
Weil jetzt müsste es eigentlich funktionieren, oder?
Ah, und es funktioniert, sonst hätte es einen Fehler gegeben, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin, ich bin blödsinnig, ich sollte hier, ich sollte hier etwas ausgeben, ich
sollte hier ein Connected ausgeben, dann weiß man, meine Talkens waren abgelaufen.
Ok, Connected, wunderbar, also das funktioniert, so, mit dem Request funktioniert es nicht.
String Builder, mit dem Request funktioniert es nicht, tatsächlich, mit dem Request funktioniert
es nicht.
Das müsste jetzt wieder funktionieren, yep, ok, da gucken wir mal, was denn jetzt der Unterschied
ist.
Ja, ich schreibe da jetzt mal 2 Dateien rein, Bilder.txt und den anderen, dann machen wir
mal einen Diff und gucken mal, was der Unterschied ist.
Ja, ich gebe zu, ohne UML Diagramm alles schwierig, aber so 20 Zeilen ohne UML Diagramm geht grad
noch so.
Guck mal, seht ihr, da sind auch Bites unterschiedlich, Diff, stimmt, Zeilenvorschub, DOS vs Unix,
könnte alles sein hier, Builder vs Request txt, äh, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok.
Das ergibt jetzt keinen Sinn, die Anzeige, schreibe auch das Richtige rein, ok, wir machen
jetzt ein diff von hand aws mqtt hexdump requests minus c exzellent
es ist es ist es ist es hast du irgendwo gesehen ja bilder.txt get ah guck mal da guck mal da
die übliche der übliche müll wieder der übliche müll ist es mal wieder
so ein dreck ich mein kann man replace line endings ja
das könnte man machen ja aber wofür gibt es denn environment newline naja in dem fall bringt
sie halt nichts wenn das mit den mit diesen raw string literals macht dann nimmt er halt das was
in der datei drinne steht run easy es funktioniert kaum machst du die richtigen line endings rein
schon funktioniert easy das heißt wir können den ganzen mist hier wait a minute request wissen
gerade ob es funktioniert please einfach funktionieren no diff und jetzt jetzt hier
kein unterschied mehr aha was ist das hier die letzte zeile ist anders 100 138 versus also
138 kann man nicht sagen das ist jeder 1 und 38 und 1 und 3a das sind space bei 0f sind space
tatsächlich wie ich das hasse mann wo ist es aws amazon.com nn da ist ein space tatsächlich
warum wo wo ist da ein space überhaupt wo ist es vielleicht bleiben wir doch lieber
string bilder das ist einfacher hier ist ein space wo kommt der her der war eben noch netter
ok ausführen hey es funktioniert bän wir haben es geschafft
sehr schön ich bin mir aber immer noch unschüssig leute jetzt war jetzt war ernsthaft moin patrick
jetzt mal ernsthaft was ist besser jetzt jetzt jetzt mal vor nachteile was findet ihr besser
den string bilder oder die string literals gibt mal reine auch show white space setting das
ist eine gute idee das sollte ich das sollte ich tatsächlich mal einstellen show white space
das ist eine gute idee interessiert ihn aber nicht wirklich achso hier ok ja vielleicht gar
nicht so blöd string literals das string bilder ist einfach nur das hier ist halt mega fehler
anfällig gell guck dir mal was passiert wir probieren jetzt mal was aus reformat
guck das reformat macht macht hier hinten leerzeichen dran das ist mega fehler anfällig
ich weiß nicht ob das so eine gute idee ist also ich tendiere zum string bilder ehrlich
gesagt ich tendiere wirklich zum string bilder reformat wird nicht ich glaube
dass ich glaube das ist nicht so fehler anfällig an sich gebe ich dir recht lesbare und schöner
ist ja das hier schon bei einem normalen string ihr da müsste ich das ja ach du meinst
einfach mit einem plus umbrechen ja das könnte man auch machen ja ich aber ich finde alternativ
könnte man auch wirklich so was hier machen also ich habe ja noch eine halbe stunde zeit
ungefähr alternativ könnte man die könnte man auch so was man ihr request so get new
line müsste man halt so so muss man halt schreiben ja slash mqtt new line query post new line
und dann das da also das ist auch nicht schön zu lesen oder könnte das jetzt höchstens
noch umbrechen dass man vielleicht ein bisschen besser lesen kann ich wäre wie gesagt ich
tendiere auch dazu dass das string bilder habe ich sogar bei dem habe ich sogar bei
dem hier den new line vergessen ich meine hiermit könnte ich mich vielleicht noch anfreunden
ja hiermit hiermit könnte ich mich vielleicht noch anfreunden weil das hier das hier geht
zu sehr das geht zu schnell kaputt dass das reform hat das kaputt macht das liegt glaube
ich hauptsächlich daran weil reiter noch ein bisschen probleme hat mit den neuen dotnet
features das ist ich meine das hier wäre auch ok oder das geht auch noch irgendwo aber
schön ist wisst ihr was leute wir bleiben einfach beim string bilder kann glaube ich
jeder kann glaube ich jeder was mit anfangen wenn er das so sieht du siehst es kommt ein
get rein und es kann halt nichts es kann nicht schief gehen da steht dann kein new line an
der falschen stelle oder so es ist halt einfach einfach genauso wie es da steht ich glaube
wir lassen ihn wir lassen in string bilder also was man ich meine wir könnten auch eine
extra klasse für dieses für diesen mqtt kram machen aber ganz im ernst wozu das ist
das ist so easy das muss ja nicht eine extra klasse auslagern sind zwei zeilen glaube
damit kann man leben aber wisst ihr was richtig cool ist wir haben jetzt im prinzip
wir haben jetzt im prinzip dieses komplette amazon beispiel hier aus diesen tausenden
dateien und allem haben wir zusammen gedampft in so 50 zeilen ungefähr 60 zeilen 70 70
70 zeilen und die sind auch noch relativ übersichtlich ja da bin ich zufrieden mit das das baue ich
bin das kann ich einbauen das ist das ist schön übersichtlich man versteht was passiert
dieses query der query bilder hier gefällt mir immer noch nicht aber gut wenn dort net
da nichts besseres zu bieten hat dann lassen wir es halt dabei gefällt mir ja park schirr
kann ja aber nicht lange ich bin gleich weg aber haben wir noch was geschafft guck mal
das gefällt mir das finde ich sehr sehr nice dann die alte tradition wir sind fertig mit
basteln wir gehen jetzt auf dings wir gehen auf mein profil und sagen konto deaktivieren
yes muss man ersten sicherheits pin vergeben ihre erste frage ihre erste antwort ja ja
wunderbar exzellent weiter ein problem ist aufgedreht oh nein oder habe ich vertippt
und es haben die erkannt dass das keine richtige frage ist kacke lull keck wie pock pock pock
pock pock lull lull was mensch ich darf jetzt darf ich meine konten schon nicht mal deaktivieren
mein profil sicherheits einstellung ok pin mein profil konto deaktivieren deaktivieren
ok ihre erste frage omega lull ihre zweite frage cute chat ajaja wunderbar sehr gute
frage alter was willst du von mir fiat was wollt ihr von mir ok ihre erste wir brauchen
eine realistische frage leute was wer war omega lull so die antwort sehr gut ist der
chat der cutest chat ever fragezeichen selbstverständlich natürlich weiter ok ok
aaah jetzt gehts ich glaube ich habe sie etwas geschockt was teilzeit arbeiten
100 prozent homeoffice oder 99 prozent homeoffice und das gehalt angeht aber ist ja gut wenn
man sich da nicht einig wird dann ist vielleicht besser es klappt halt klappt halt nicht also
für mich ist halt homeoffice das wichtigste weil ansonsten kann ich einfach da bleiben
wo ich jetzt bin wenn ich vier stunden am tag fahren will jetzt wurde das konto deaktiviert
excellent die mail bestätigten zum account löschen das wäre das wäre auch was aber
wie gesagt also die leute haben einen äußerst motivierten eindruck gemacht ich fand das fand
das an sich wirklich nice die was sie gefragt haben so alles vollkommen in ordnung und technisch
hat das auch alles gepasst wie gesagt sie waren glaube ich nicht so ganz glücklich
mit vier tage die woche arbeiten und dass ich so bestanden habe so drauf beharrt habe
auf 99 besser 100 prozent homeoffice obwohl ich extra dazu gesagt habe wenn es halt irgendwelche
events gibt oder kickoffs oder wichtige sachen oder was kaputt ist kann man ja auch schon
mal vor ort fahren aber ansonsten wäre mir wichtig dass es eine remote stelle ist das
hat auch nicht so viel begeisterung gestoßen ich glaube vor allem im personal aber gut
mein was willst du machen ja ich sag halt was für mich wichtig ist und wenn es am ende
nicht passt was was wollen wir machen besser ist es einem jetzt klar als dass dann am ende
was rauskommt was irgendeinem nicht passt deswegen das ist mir schon wichtig dass was
geregelt ist mit dem homeoffice weil auf irgendwelche aussagen wo man dann sich da im halben jahr
nicht mehr dran erinnern kann das kenne ich da habe ich leider erfahrungen schon mit
gemacht deswegen bin ich da so erpicht drauf dass das eben auch passiert
das problem ist halt diese noch weiter weg als mein aktueller job aktuell kann ich ja wenn alles
gut läuft in 40 45 minuten da sein dort brauche ich dann zwei stunden einfach ja zwei stunden
in zwei stunden zurück und das mache ich garantiert nicht einmal die woche das ganze never das
mache ich vielleicht irgendwie mal eine handvoll im jahr wenn es hochkommt zwei drei mal im
jahr wenn irgendwelche kickoff events oder wichtige sachen sind ok aber ansonsten nope
also da werden wenn wir uns nicht einig werden sonst das ist für mich wichtig 100 prozent
homeoffice ja das mag ja beim chef vielleicht doch der fall sein es lässt sich aber leider
oder was heißt leider glücklicherweise nicht auf jeden übertragen also ich mache definitiv
im büro deutlich weniger weil ich mich deutlich weniger konzentrieren kann als daheim laufen
irgendwie einer am tisch steht und irgendwas will oder irgendwie einer sonst was einfach nur
neben mir telefoniert ich kann mich einfach deutlich besser daheim konzentrieren ich schaffe
mehr ja und das müsste eigentlich für alle seiten das beste sein
ja gucken wir mal mal gucken was da rauskommt vielleicht überlegen sie sich das ja dass das
mit vier tagen und homeoffice so schlecht ist ansonsten ich bin ja glücklicherweise in der
position dass ich nicht zwangsläufig was neues brauche ich hatte kein bock auf den aktuellen
laden mehr aus unterschiedlichsten gründen aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht gezwungen mir
instant was neues zu suchen ich bin da in einer ganz guten position eigentlich ganz
ehrlich ich kommuniziere mit den leuten im homeoffice besser als auf der arbeit im homeoffice
weißt du immer wenn einer grün ist ist auch erreichbar im teams und sowas und nicht wie
vor ort wo du mal vorbei läufst dann ist er nicht da oder geht nicht ans telefon und sonst
was teams weiß ja typisch grün der typisch da und ich habe mehr von den leuten von meinen
kollegen mitbekommen in homeoffice zeit als im büro klingt zwar widersprüchlich ist bei uns aber
so aber dass ich gebe zu ich kann mich so weit rein versetzen dass man das schlecht nachvollziehen
können suchst du selber irgendwelche punten hast du hätte aber aufsteigt weder noch ich hatte die
letzten zehn jahre über zwei vorstellungsgespräche also ist nicht so alt habe ich wahnsinnig viel
übung da drinnen und die sind beide male entstanden dadurch dass mich jemand angeschrieben
hat so nach dem motto max willst du nicht zu uns ich habe kein finger bis ich um gemacht erstens
weil ich mega faul bin was sowas angeht und wahrscheinlich ist es noch nicht akut genug aber
wie gesagt homeoffice technisch ist halt das was mich am meisten stört dort wo ich aktuell bin
und dass die da irgendwie auch keine ich weiß nicht keine entgegenkommen zeigen deswegen bin
ich höchstwahrscheinlich wenn sich das wenn sich da was ergibt zum 31 12 weg also ich kündige
dann zum 31 12 wenn wenn wenn ich bis dahin was neues haben ansonsten gucke ich gucke ich
weiter und wenn ich was habe mache ich dann das andere was ich auch immer dann finde oder aber sie
überlegen sich sollten auch mal dann bleibe ich auch da weil an sich wie gesagt macht die leute
und an sich finde ich es auch nicht schlecht aber der umgang mit homeoffice hat mir nicht gefallen
ja das stimmt schon wie gesagt du merkst doch sofort wer ahnung hat also was du im homeoffice
sofort merkt sind leute die mal erfahrungen haben mit mmos oder in multiplayer spielen weil
leute die multiplayer erfahrungen haben sei es jetzt irgendwelche rate gilden mitgemacht haben
oder sei es auch nur csgo gespielt irgendwie im ts mit leuten gehockt du merkst das die haben
ordentliches equipment die wissen was push to talk ist und wissen einfach wie man sich online in
dem voice chat verhält so dass es gut funktioniert also nicht das mikrofon den poppers stecken haben
nicht irgendwie wackelkontakte haben nicht irgendwie die kinder im hintergrund rumschreien zu haben
ohne scheiß weil das ist du merkst es sofort wer online spielerfahrung hat ist der richtige
giga chat im homeoffice das merkst du auch gleich du merkst sofort wer online spielerfahrung hat
das sind die die das ohne probleme sofort hinbekommen und mit denen es super angenehm ist in teams zu
labern und sich auszutauschen online alles kein problem aber du merkst auch gleich bei den leuten
wo das nicht so ist ja genau gerade push to talk leute push to talk wenn du im hintergrund die
kinder hast push to talk ist das beste was dafür gibt ja das sind auch leute die wissen genau wie
chats wie chat räume funktionieren die schreiben dann keine email also es gibt ja leute die haben
das bei uns bis heute noch nicht gecheckt die gehen in teams channels und schreiben dann da rein
sehr geehrte damen und herren der service ist seit gestern nacht gestört wir bitten um schnellst
mögliche entstörung mit den besten grüßen euer service team wo ich mir immer denke alter das ist
ein chat schreib halt rein service xy ist laut unserer meldung kaputt kannst du mal gucken oder
sowas das finde ich dann immer so bescheuert wenn du leute hast wo du richtig spürst so ihr habt
keine ahnung wie man chats verwendet oder wie man voice chat im internet macht wie ist er nicht so
dass in der it nicht auch leute gibt so ist es nett also es gibt genug leute auch in der
it die so sind die so drauf sind auch eine beliebte frage ist bist du gerade da da neige
ich immer drauf lieber nicht zu antworten weil leute die nicht gleich schreiben was sache ist
die wollen meistens etwas unangenehmes wobei doch ich antworte eigentlich so gut wie immer
drauf außer es ist jemand der mich nervt von dem ich schon weiß dass er mich nervt wie zum
beispiel unserer koordinator der nicht koordinieren will das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt
machen wir hier die vm aus gut leute wir hatten einen äußerst produktiven mittags bis nachmittags
schrieben heute wir haben tatsächlich was sinnvolles hinbekommen von dem ich nicht gedacht
hätte dass es so einfach ist das nachzubauen jetzt kann ich endlich in mein projekt einbauen und
den nix können wir dann auch in home assistant messages von unseren autos über mqtt empfangen
und automatisches hof da aufmachen und solche dinger und ich gehe jetzt meine zwei stunden
rumlaufen noch und wir sehen uns im nächsten stream leute macht's gut bis denn zu